salut à tous c'est les pêcheurs de
trésors aujourd'hui nous sommes à
Avignon bon voilà vous aurez bien fait
un tour des citadelles etc mais nous ce
qu'on cherche c'est les endroits où on
est susceptible de trouver des belles
choses dans l'eau donc là on est au bord
d'un lac et j'ai repéré quelque chose il
y a une formation particulière en face
sans tomber
des amis pêcheurs qui est en train de
manger leur truc oh les capsules et les
clous
je pense que ça jamais été pêché à
l'aimant
de réussir à sortir tous ces éléments et
après on recommence sur ton objectif
spécial là-bas ça se soulève c'est un
écran un écran ou une télé
encore si ça doit être terrible
allez le trophée
électronique bizarre
je sais pas trop ce que c'est si vous
avez en commentaire et en même temps
regardez ça une douille qui a été
percuté donc
c'est du 17 57 oh ça fait penser du
kalachnikov ouais
intéressant surtout tirer c'est pas mal
quelqu'un
comme dirait Bondy trésor Hunter
tu m'as mouillé avec cette dégueulasse
je m'en excuse rien ce que j'aimerais
sortir aujourd'hui justement c'est un
AK-47 parce que c'est vrai que les armes
automatiques c'est pas notre truc on
fait des pistolets on fait des revolver
mais les fusils de chasse mais on
aimerait bien trouver un petit AK-47 ça
nous ferait plaisir bon bien sûr on le
garderait pas non mais il paraît que ça
chauffe pas mal à Avignon donc c'est
pour ça qu'on est ici aussi ouais c'est
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de spots aussi
donc on va voir pour l'instant beaucoup
de canettes
que tu le sens je le sens frotte sur les
capsules
avec du cuivre dedans une bobine de
cuivre oh pas mal
ça c'est ah bah c'est un morceau de
moulinet je reconnais impossible
encore
j'ai quelque chose d'assez gros ça fait
un petit cloque donc j'espère que je
vais réussir à le garder tout le long là
vous sortez la corde qui frotte et vous
vous avez un petit peu une leçon du
poids quand même je dirais deux trois
kilos
intéressant en sachant que maintenant il
se charge de capsules de bière allez on
va regarder ensemble ce qu'on a
et je dédicace cette découverte c'est
une caisse ah ça c'était sûr ici
malheureusement il était ouverte
ok mais ça fait plaisir c'est bon signe
c'est une pitchounette pas
écouté intéressant on va regarder sur
les mains s'il y a pas quelques pièces
de 5 centimes ça pourrait nous donner
une indication pour savoir si elle était
quoi une pierre il y a un dépôt sauvage
de clous ici ça va être coton de
nettoyer ça
il y en avait d'autres
on testera là-bas où il y a le pêcheur
aussi ça a l'air sympa parce qu'il y a
une rampe pour envoyer un scooter là
direct
ouais mais bon
OK
je pense
tout de suite non
il y a des vieilles choses
et puis je pensais que le plus que ça
reste raisonnable
malheureusement le protoxyde d'azote on
risque d'en faire pas mal aujourd'hui
de cette semi-drogue pas encore
considéré comme un drogue en France mais
qui commence à être dans pas mal de pays
et on va faire un petit lancer de la
main droite attention
avec une canette de Pepsi collector
c'est horrible
si je finis pas avec un coup planté dans
la main avant la fin de la journée ce
sera un miracle de paire dedans là c'est
pas possible
les capsules oh là je vois quelque chose
au mieux une montre à gousset miniature
waouh
ah oui d'accord ah oui
regarde
elle est jolie elle brille bien
la couche
mais elle ressort bien
bah écoute c'est ma deuxième montre ici
donc je vais continuer
on peut pas se baigner l'autre salle
des trucs bizarres toi tu t'en sors mais
si tu as deux heures de route avant de
prendre la douche c'est bon
jus comme ça
incroyable
mais il y a des coins en France à Paris
et tout c'est terrible
les chercher un autre saut
oh là là
j'ai pas envie j'ai plus envie
c'est un enfant
c'est un enfer bon ça m'a fait penser à
une idée si jamais vous devez vous
débarrasser d'un objet compromettant
vous le jetez à l'eau et vous venez
vider des brouettes de clous par dessus
je pense que n'importe quel pêcheur elle
est mort va remonter deux trois fois les
mains comme ça et puis j'attrape plus
son aimant et votre objet sera en
sécurité au fond de l'eau pensez à
revenir de temps en temps pour rajouter
des clous et c'est bon c'est OK ouais on
a repéré un petit lac qui a l'air bien
sympa et on arrive à peine sur place et
on trouve cet indice c'est plutôt
bizarre d'après sa rouille il a pas ses
journées dans l'eau je pense pas très
peu là il est plus rouillé ici en tout
cas c'est un cadre de grosse scooter
peugeot et ça pèse franchement une
trentaine de kilos déjà
ouais c'est prometteur pour ce qui va y
avoir dans l'eau donc nous ce qu'on va
faire c'est qu'on va sortir nos aimants
et on va tout de suite attaquer la pêche
à la main bien sûr on est en compagnie
de race
voilà le spot
alors je crois que j'ai pas de ferraille
mais j'ai encore plein d'algues avec des
écrevisses
et elles sont plutôt grosses par rapport
à leur taille habituel dans le coin donc
on va les écouter on va les récolter on
va les manger de toute façon c'est des
écrevisses de Louisiane je pense que
c'est interdit de les relâcher
regardez elles sont belles
et en même temps on va quand même
regarder les mains si on a pas de la
ferraille
quelques bouts
ok ça c'est très ancien
de la pêche aux écrevisses je sais pas
si vous connaissez la chaîne de Marius
le chasse et pêche alors nous on est pas
trop chasse mais c'est vrai que ces
écrevisse là en plus c'est interdit de
les relâcher donc pour le coup je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on va vraiment chasser
les écrevisses et on va aller pêchons
des écrevisses
on va vous faire une pêche à l'écrevisse
avec des aimants
ma première
et toi je t'ai vu
encore une
autre par là qui se cache
une de plus
je pense
pour l'instant tu en as une toi
j'en vois déjà une
pas mal encore une fois et ta deuxième
Marius chasse et pêche n'a qu'à bien se
tenir
ça marche bien
pourquoi la pêche
mais là quand c'est des trucs invasif en
vrai ça me ça me rassure d'un côté tu
vois
tout ça
il y en a une adresse
c'est pas une de Louisiane je pense
bonjour
elle m'a passé elle m'a eu là
oui je l'ai eu
une casserole
bah c'est parfait ça pour faire cuire
nos écrevisses regardez on a tout ce
qu'il faut maintenant plus qu'à faire un
petit feu là et on est bon
on sort les algues
et là normalement il faut regarder
j'en ai une
et voilà
et là il y en a une autre
et de deux
et voilà le résultat de la pêche élément
du jour donc là on va se faire ça au
barbecue ça va être très bon
si vous avez déjà goûté des écrevisses
de rivière comme ça ça m'étonnerait
parce que très peu de personnes
[Musique]
et on a de la Ferrari en même temps pour
le ferrailleur c'est cool
allez rasta en selle